le pigeon alors voilà
la symbolique des 3 la saint valentin a
été inventé pour des profils comme celui
ci mais profil de jongh pelard extrême
non mais c'est vrai faut voir l
américain serait bien le pigeon extrême
oui à mon avis là ça va être un truc de
jongh pelard mais un truc de caisse qui
va faire ce soir le pigeon oui bien
votre audace et valentin
[Rires]
badigeon pis alors il ya bruit fatto est
en partie ma compagne est en partie à
l'international bon allez
on passe pas s'arrête pas là c'est chaud
juste
c'est normal que ça me va pas pour la
somalie
tout pour l'éviter un problème et a eu
un problème
de problème un problème reste au
parisien c'est par internationale oui
oui il est clairement cocu
[Applaudissements]
on va dire
qu est ce qu a aller
alors non mais gilles eux
commencent à se fier qu'à
l'international pendant la saint
valentin est la dure depuis huit ans
elle a trouvé le juste c'est vrai j'ai
trouvé ça bizarre quand je les remets à
l'aéroport vendredi elle était allée
elle part ou au sénégal est d'accord
vendredi
et donc je vous jure que je vous dis la
vérité ça me gêne ça me gêne de
l'apprendre comme ça non pour les
téléspectateurs j'ai raté la fête là bas
moi ça me fait de la peine tiens tu veux
mais c'est vrai que mes gars qu'elle t'a
dit maintenant que vous me dites ça
arrêtez de me harceler parce que je
commence à flipper et maintenant que
vous me dites ça je commence à me
demander pourquoi elle est partie
n'allait pas réfléchi du tout dans les
bouts surtout demandez vous sur iphone
va jamais revenir
[Rires]
j'en ai collé alors je ne veux pas je
veux pas jouer les oiseaux de mauvais
augure y aller avec qui elle est pour
moi il était parti au sénégal moi j'suis
pas méchant moi mon avis elle a
rencontré quelqu'un je veux pas alors
moi
non mais j'y retourne au maroc et nous
emmerde
[Rires]
c'est pas du mar je vous adore quand
même
châssis mais moi aussi parce que
maintenant vous me fait réfléchir
je n'ai pas à lui si je peux me
permettre on va pas voir sa famille pour
la saint valentin ben moi c'est quand
même dans tous les cas si c'est pas la
ramie sexy
mais bella appelle les perco si je peux
me permettre vraiment
de ce dernier le dernier pays où soit
allé là c'est le sénégal c'est la fête
totale ils viennent de gagner la coupe
vont pas gagner que la coupe d'afrique
mais c'est vrai la partie seul j'en à
l'aéroport qu'elle était sous prétexte
qu'elle a été son prêt techniques et des
papiers administratifs
[Applaudissements]
je te dis c'est une grosse comme les
paquets
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va pas se mentir médailles soit qu'il
n'a plus franchement aimé la plus
sensible aux prunes a la vida hymne est
ce que tu crois cette affaire alors ça
me fait énormément de mal déjà quand tu
bafouille comme ça
fait énormément de mal pour gilles parce
que je sais à quel point ils portent pas
tous dans son coeur mais elle
visiblement c'est elle et encore plus
dans son cas est en face à mu est elle
en train de s'amuser et à lui elle se
donne au passage ils s'amusent et se
joue de toi et gilles est ce que je peux
te poser une question puisque là l'heure
est grave il est 18 heures 48 vous
faites ça pas mal de gens qui réagissent
même sa mère l'a envoyé un sms à ma mère
m'envoyait c'est m ce jeu et de le lire
dit
bailly les palombes je vais te le dire
voilà
pauvre gilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et deuxième question de ma mère qui
m'emmène question fatou et elle part qu'
avec la bague
de vos fesses et par rapport à vous
alors non mais j'ai une révélation à
vous faire dans la lah pour l'instant on
va on fera les révélations dans un
instant là pas mal donc on va tout
reprendre depuis le début oui un bon
signe ou quand ce voyage au sénégal at
il été prévue mardi ou mercredi dernier
mercredi elle est partie pour vendredi
qu'est ce qu'elle a évoqué scala vos
règlements de papier mise alors attendez
pour rentrer le soir elle vous l'a dit
au téléphone ou une bise de visu
alors elle m'a dit tu peux m'aider pour
le billère le sénégal en plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous savez quoi j'ai l'impression d'être
julien combes est
vraiment vraiment ça m'a donné vraiment
alors et donc le cauchemar a démarré
quand elle vous adore mais elle vous
indique pourquoi je vous ai dit qu'elle
parte au sénégal pour régler des papiers
parce qu'il ya des papiers qui traînent
et elle veut elle a pas juste le moment
la saint valentin ils craignent de
fréquences et pertinents
trois quatre ans
j'arrive trois quatre ans on devrait
elle n'avance pas donc eh ben oui pour
de vrai je mange mon pas oui blessé ni
ça suffit jbl reste quand même temps
trois semaines
[Applaudissements]
nourrit d'abord il te dit je te dis une
semaine avant la saint-valentin bonjour
je donne alors parce que lorsque la
semaine dernière elle lui dit il ya une
semaine je vais partir trier des
papilles c'est les gars qui traîne
depuis trois quatre ans pendant trois
semaines et toi tu dois payer combat
pour le billet vous voyez pas que c'est
un homme qui ne veut pas voir la vérité
tous les deux on attendait ben oui mais
si bob n'était pas là bas j'ai loué chez
nous tu te leur nom laisse une amie mais
[Rires]
tu la connais la nuit ont fait ça oui
est ce qu'on peut vous demander un truc
ne pleurez pas l'appeler on dirait que
oui non mais vous pouvez l'appeler vous
avez son numéro moi j'ai jamais mon
téléphone ici elle m'avait demandé
d'aller au cinéma avec elle joue cache
pas
il appelait sur ses passions dubernard
mans j'avais peur je prenne une autre a
touché a noté mais gilles ça va oui bah
vous me mettez le dos la mer aucune
raison qu'on était tous contents et
qu'on avait prévu une une saint valentin
par par facetime et aux yeux
de m le mec là il a créé une saint
valentin mais en fait ça
[Rires]
john vous me faites géorgie de raison de
douter
les chéris j'aimerais avoir l'avis de
géraldine maillet
qui est sage bombages il
commence ma benz a fait une femme oui tu
es sur wii alors que moi je pense qu'en
fait c'est quelque part la fin d'une
histoire
dure j'étais pas venu comme ça pour ça
moi
n'avaient de tourner autour du pot
mariage pas mariage promesses pas
promesses
il faut voir les choses en face
quand je parle pas cette excuse de
papier en fait il y est c'est un alibi
en fait
la pub tu devrais te le dis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à tout le monde avec moi
[Rires]
[Musique]
le pauvre c'est tellement joli mais ça
va non je rigole et
gilles allais je vous dis pas que l'état
soit
il dit la vérité oui bah c'est vous lost
and found
là je te parle s'allongera là mon ami
[Rires]
pendant l'émission
est ce que c'est vrai tous qui sommes
nous on a rajouté mais c'est rien a
ajouté j'ai emmené fatou vendredi matin
pour le vol d'air sénégal de 10 heures à
roissy au dos et
[Applaudissements]
j'étais avec elle après elle m'a dit oh
je crois que j'ai oublié mon ordi à la
maison pour travailler
j'ai repris la voiture pour aller
chercher
et et d'un coup elle m'avait appelé mais
comme le téléphone ça mais pas 509
finalement j'ai bien leur dis dans mon
voilà c'est pas la peine que tu
reviennes
avec le dire c'est là
qu'elle est partie au sénégal c'est un
film à la reçut un texto et du gars qui
parle de paris avec elle il a dit je
suis là dans cinq minutes qui lui a dit
vas chercher l'aéroport dit rechercher
l'ordi mais il s'est barré chercher leur
dit il il a rencontré dès qu'on l'a on
s'emballe
serge il s'était fait rare chez les gars
bizarre choix de douane à plaire sénégal
votez 2 si l'émulation
ému du tout il réfléchit rien à voir ces
interrogations parce que vous êtes fin
vous êtes cérébrale corps
et si finalement la mine n'avait pas
raison mais non c'est pas possible non
pas au nom pas possible maintenant est
ce que vous en pensez vous sert il à
titre personnel personne n'est
venu alors l'amie de j je vais vous
parler on n'est pas là je vous parle
[Rires]
j'ai parlé de l'ex de file au
canada il avait vraiment que je vous
dise que j'en pense mais oui parce que
au nom de l'amitié voilà vraiment au nom
de l'amitié je vais dire des choses qui
avec des moyens aux amis well amélioré
aux amis là j'ai dit la vérité montlaur
dont la leur dis gentiment oui sentiment
le préserve a dit mme neuville pas que
c'est la fête du slip au sénégal en ce
moment
ce que je ne dois pas lui dire j'adore
me dites pas que c'est la fête du slip
actuellement d'accord géraldine ne lui
dites pas que c'est foutu d'accord ne
dit pas qu'il est en ligne sur steam
dans ce matin qui était à boulogne en
afrique ali ne lui dites pas que calais
partie avec un autre benjamin ne le dit
pas qu'elle est partie à cause de lui
si chanson ça michelle et she
rebondissements dans la sphère 1 1 fatou
vient d'appeler
magnifique fatou vient d'appeler dingue
alors si on a le téléphone de gilles
fait entrer via sais
pas combien a pris
car le code et je vais appeler on va
appeler fatoumatou va t'appeler
apparemment confiant sur vous l'avez
compris elle n'est pas du sénégal ce que
je crois pas qu'il nous regarde
directement entre eux mêmes en faisant
le code la
tulle et c'est bon la prod sa fouille
dans nos affaires c'est la poitrine aux
affaires
avec mon aval
on avale sa chance ces contractuels sûr
que d'ailleurs on peut dire la pointe de
m'amener mon slip
c'est un excuse moi en tout cas on met
deux heures et ça y est ça y est le
holà oula oula rien non plus ah oui ha
oui pal fatou
a bien pauvre chat qui m'appelle je
crois que ce n'est pas tout
il ya du décalage horaire allô allô
allô
si vous êtes l'amande fatou répondait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous êtes la mode pas tous
décliné notre identité nous sommes
atteints de
maladies préserver à l'occ et la
tchéquie
et là je suis d'avoir de fatou
mais non je ne sais pas qui vous appelle
au secours moi non plus je sais pas mais
vous m'avez dit que vous l'appeliez ma
part ce sont d'abord maison téléphone
alors c'est pas très beau rappel non
mais c'est pas mal je sais pas si
quelqu'un qui nous appellent les secours
appelés
cyril mais voilà jérôme tremblay
piloter dans les eaux c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qui a valorisé ce jeu tout à
l'heure
j'ai pas la photo c'est sûr qu'on a pas
s'engueuler donne
des stray sheep à d'autres talents photo
oui on a l'amour non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
photo pas tout calme automne j'ai pas
seul
oui c'est moi mais je ne suis pas sale
padoue
fatou fatous cyril hanouna
comment vas tu ça va pas tout
ça tout ça va mais tu sais c'est le
coeur lourd que je l'appelle ma chérie
je t'aime beaucoup va tout bah oui on
est une raison pour laquelle tu nous
réclament ta bague non tu peux la bague
tu peux la garder ma chérie même
tellement que tu me réclament cas vague
la bac tu peux la garder la seule chose
que je demande
c'est la vérité
avec un grand v
par rapport à quoi où es-tu fatou je
suis à dakar je suis en famille je suis
au sénégal
d'accord il fatto je vais trop posé la
même question la vérité
de ma famille à tous
va-t-on comment se fait-il que tu sois
parti pour la saint-valentin fatto
il fallait que je sois la
chine a
longtemps fait tomber amoureux
[Applaudissements]
sur place vous plaît j'aurai quelque
chose à te dire arrête tu es salaam
allègre à tout
va tout lâcher hanouna l'un à
à tous
comment se fait-il que tu sois parti
maintenant
[Musique]
et j'espère la saint-valentin
d'accord donc tu es
fatou qu tu veux m'assurer qu'à dakar
tu es seul avec ta famille
pas tout est-ce qu'il t'avait d'être
main dans la main avec ton cousin
[Rires]
[Musique]
quoi l'être pour la paix des ménages
mais parfaitement jeu de shereni fait
d'accord mais dis donc fatto on peut
avoir confiance on peut faire l'émission
tranquille
et ben non
[Rires]
photo aidera tôt que l'abbé piétons
d'accor gilles a quelque chose à dire
pour la saint valentin parce que fatou
tu m'as convaincu
tu m'as convaincu fatou
jeu pato en tout cas je ne sais pas si
tu dis la vérité mais tu très persuasive
bravo matthew fattouche te pas gilles
tefaatau on t'aime tu sais
on t'aime pas tout
mais
le bateau je suis avec gilles
à quelques mètres de moi
il est à quelques encablures l'a donc si
tu pouvais un lever le pied sur nos
débats merci
à tous
photo je serai je serais d'accord
certainement vendredi
pato stockage il
faut que je te passe gilles et fatou je
vais te laisser une minute pour lui dire
toute la vérité
gilles c'est pour toi c'est pas tout
ça va série excusez moi vous dis pas
qu'on ne retombe mal déjà voulait mettre
la boutique whitaker ça va alors voilà
c'est ce qu'on va faire et c'est ce
qu'on va faire parce qu'on a en direct
là alors on va faire une révélation à
cyril on va lui dire ce que tu m'as dit
hier voilà tu vas lui dira cyril il vat
entendre qu est ce que tu es parti faire
préparer le mariage
c'est si bon de crier victoire c'est
bien avec gilles
pas tous des fatwas si on met les sépare
les familles j'aimerais qu'elle le dise
oui à tout
mais il vient de lui quand même
il va passer quand même n'est pas invité
d'accord et le mariage sera au sénégal
énorme
atout photo
photo c'est moi c'est cyrille
patoux à toi tu viens de dire nous dire
à tous que ça y est vous allez vous
marier avec gilles
fatou
au sénégal
mais quant
aux autres au sénégal
c'est génial on sera vite et
il y en a que pour des raisons bien sûr
que tu finir
je serai là alors pas tout je viendrai
sache le et là je viens vite jouer bien
dans les hôtels n'est pas comme une fois
que je serai là ma chérie que je serai
là et fattouche fatou je voulais dire
que c'est un très grand jour pour nous
parce que pour la saint valentin on
pouvait pas rêver
pas tous je suis très heureux pour toi
ma chérie vraiment parce que j'y croyais
plus à ce mariage
non mais c'est vrai il ya eu deux
mariages auxquels je croyais plus et
tais-toi et gilles et raymond domenech
estelle denis follana
des mots qui va se faire
non mais c'est vrai c'est fini et je
vais être passé gilles parce que il veut
te dire quelque chose
gilles n'est pas blanc bleu depuis sept
mois
je l'appelle à que vous comptez tout
gâcher alors
je veux lui faut juillet la vérité sur
daniel moreau à
toi je te bat jill klaatu et et merci
fatou qui dit-il lui et lui dit qu'est
ce que tu veux mais utilisé au petit
coeur the theme mars et on
va tous les invités
[Rires]
oui
j'imagine la croyable une allonge 1 m m
au t1 et georges il nous a bien venu
mais franchement il m'a dit ma fille
parce que je suis au courant de rien il
m'a pris j'ai genre il savait que
j'avais eue grâce et shaw wood à la nasa
savait pas et après pour me dire bah je
ne payais savait pas c'est fou à qui
nous avons trop ses plus beaux jours du
trésor mais je ne savais pas du tout
fonctionne avec fatou si sûr abbas et
elle vous l'a dit en direct on a dit
plein de choses
les bouffées
[Applaudissements]
elle est même connu
ça mais c'est vrai
je vous dis donc il mais hier elle m'a
dit ça mais si elle quitte à demander en
fait quitte and its elle m'a dit s est
pas fait comme salt and i o oui parce
qu'allah dakhabrakha parce que je veux
faire des papiers elle règle les
affaires non mais elle n'est pas parti
pour préparer le mariage nous expliquer
les partis pour des papiers urgent il a
été invité à un mariage dès son arrivée
samedi dimanche deux jours et elle m'a
dit franchement il faut qu'on aille se
maria dakar annoncé hier moi je vous dit
tout ce parent st
n'at-on pas crier victoire
j'ai raison voilà c'est pas clair mais
sans éclat
j'adore fatou après les parties à dakar
pour partir à damer les mecs mais vous
connaissez pas des mecs connaissait pas
les techniques de ces 2 mai mais les
délégués de chacun mais je connais moi
mais dis moi je suis un renard argenté
mois
premier un bail à partir du bois
et biomasse marier après côté marnais
toi tu as trahi sa maison serait d'abord
avec moi ce soir
sans déconner à lacanau à la kapisa
[Applaudissements]
parmi ces
sans déconner s'est pas posée tous les
moyens sont bons
gilles est ce que alors question pour la
saint valentin est ce que si fatou n'est
pas au courant voilà l époque ou en
personne ne le saura est ce que tu
pourrais passer la nuit avec dernier le
moment mais personne ne le sait
même pas toi personne de celui-ci non
mais lui le sait
[Rires]
ça c'est vrai lc béliveau slip
non mais ça alors est ce que oui ou non
je pensais que vous étiez mon ami vous
mais personne d'autre choix maintenant
si pour daniela oui si tu avais une idée
assez fait ou non mais elle est fausse
et futurs
[Applaudissements]
là
c'était tous extraordinaires